thank you very much for that wonderful
applause I I think I know why this
liberal audience is happy today the
Supreme Court announced today that they
will decide this summer whether all 50
states must allow gay marriage which is
a pretty big thing to the Supreme Court
ago and they said this is it so they're
going to set aside more than they
usually do time for oral arguments ago
decide two and a half hours for oral
arguments and three for anal I'm just
kidding the other reason why you're
happy three-day weekend right that's
right Monday is Martin Luther King Day
or as it's known to the Academy Awards
Monday
well I say that you know because the
Academy Award nominations came out this
week and no blacks in any of the major
categories kind of a scandal yeah but
the British did very well if you like
white people they do they [ __ ]
cleaned up let me tell you imitation
game did you see that Windows with Best
Picture nominee and also theory of
everything yeah that the money that the
British movies are about a brilliant
physicist and a brilliant mathematician
the American movies are but a wrestler a
drummer and a sniper everything an idiot
wants to be when he's 10 what but if
their movies beat our movies our movies
are gonna beat them up in the cafeteria
after the sale
yeah American sniper interesting up
against Selma which is little weird
since Martin Luther King was killed by a
sniper so I'm not looking forward to
that dance number Meryl Streep got a
nomination they didn't say what for they
just assumed ah and Keira Knightley got
a nomination yeah they got her on the
phone at dawn she said she was so
nervous she hadn't eaten since 2006
but enough about our petty concerns here
in Hollywood everybody in the country is
talking about is how to live in this new
era of dangerous fanatical ideology but
enough about the new Republican Congress
terrorism is also pretty scary out there
in the world do you see this police in
Belgium interrupted what was gonna be a
terrible attack just like in France here
in Ohio we arrested a homegrown
terrorist and Obama still trying to make
it up to the French for not going over
there for the big March on Sunday which
he should that was a boner really were
laughing at Boehner so what he did was
he sent John Kerry over to Paris I swear
to God did you see this with James
Taylor who sang to them you've got a
friend which actually went over very
well actually James Taylor should have
quit while he was ahead then he wound up
playing his other hits and he played the
exact wrong song for the French shower
the people which
they they took as a dig they don't
[ __ ] shower did you ever hear about
that the French stone Shepherd get out
but look we definitely should have gone
to that March and to his credit the
White House did did acknowledge that but
you know Obama he's always cool about
this [ __ ] he's like yeah we'll go next
time sound like you guys in Europe we're
gonna run out of crazy Muslim terrorists
okay meanwhile over in Saudi Arabia they
have delayed the next public flogging
there was a dealer about this there was
a blogger a blogger got flogged say that
three times fast for insulting Islam and
he gets a thousand lashes that's the
penalty and of course you can't do that
all at once so they gave him fifty
supposed to get fifty a week but they
found out he still is not recovered from
the first fifty so they delayed the next
fifty see there are moderate Muslims oh
the the brave brave people at Sharlee at
BO better hope so and by the way these
people have balls the size of Gerard
Depardieu they really did they put out
their next issue by the way sold three
million copies with a yeah
with a certain profit on the cover I'm
not gonna say which one uh you know it
took us ten years to rebuild the World
Trade Center France went back to
insulting people like that but not
everyone agrees the Pope this is so sad
I I was starting to really like this
Pope he's dead to me now oh yeah [ __ ]
the Pope well look George Bush said it
you were the with us or against us okay
apparently the Pope is not with us
because he came down on the side of the
bad guys he said you cannot provoke you
cannot insult someone's faith you cannot
make fun of the faith of others I guess
he doesn't get HBO
and then and then the Pope the Vicar of
Christ the representative of the Prince
of Peace I swear to God I [ __ ] with you
not mimic punching someone in the face
he pointed to his aide and he said you
know what if luigi here
um giuseppe whatever his name is made
from a month made fun of my mother oh
yes just like jesus said I think it's in
Galatians 13 when Jesus said turn the
other cheek into my fist you [ __ ]
Mook maybe I'm miss porting it but okay
this was in the paper today headline in
the New York Times ocean life faces mass
extinction is that bad
I think that's bad also the officially
now from NASA and the oceanic people
2014 the hottest year ever since we
started recording how long before the
Republicans stop denying this I mean
just look at the data look at the
IceCaps look at John Bainer --zf eighth
and the man who mocked Obama for saying
the oceans were rising remember that
Mitt Romney back in the race jumping in
with two feet there he was at the RNC
convention this year and not the
convention but they have their winter
meeting down in San Diego
I like this the organizers put him to
make his speech on the USS Midway a
mothballed aircraft carrier that has
outlived its usefulness
I wonder if he got the hint and you know
they're Republicans they're all sniping
at each other Mitt Romney's getting back
in Rand Paul said MIT running again is
the definition of insanity yeah he said
he quoted Einstein we're not sure if
it's Einstein but he said remember that
famous quote when you do the same thing
over and over again with expectation of
a different result
that's insane now again we don't know if
that was Einstein who said that whoever
said don't do the same thing over and
over again we don't know but it wasn't
Bill Cosby